[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres rezept ich
werde beim namen kuchenbacken bananen
brot sondern ins team meisten ich bin
heute hier in unserer kleinen privaten
schicken küche denn unsere küche drüben
ist belegt morath treter gerade ein
video mit sturm naja das mal gucken ob
ich die küche wieder heile
zurückbekommen ansonsten gewöhnen wir
uns einfach an diese küche hier und ich
drehe auch sofort hier
da kann man es auch machen japan an
kuchen da gibt es tausende rezepte viele
machen das ganz klasse spiele machen
vegan und ich habe mir gedacht wir
machen heute einmal die ganz klassische
version sli version und einmal dann noch
eine vegane version möchte ich einfach
zeige welche zutaten hier austauschen
könnt um das bananen brot eben auch
vegan zuzubereiten vielen jetzt wann
dann brot aber für mich ist einfach ein
kuchen weil es ist halt kein brot aber
egal ich sage ich mal kurz die zutaten
ich denke dafür 180 gramm mehl 1
teelöffel backpulver eine prise salz und
ein viertel teelöffel zimt 70 gramm koks
blüten zucker 50k mandeln die habe ich
bereits fein gemahlen zweier manager
extrakte reife bananen und hier habe ich
noch 75 gramm butter dass ich muss schon
sagen die bananen sind nicht so reif die
sind schon besser also die dürfen ruhig
so aussehen
die nehme ich dann auch und da nehme ich
drei und sollten ungefähr 300 gramm sein
also geschehen das gewicht ich weg die
gleich ab was mache ich jetzt
zuallererst ich werde die butter
schmelzen das mache ich jetzt hier ganze
butter schmelzen dann kann ich schon mal
die bananen shell und wiegen
ich liebte die banane jetzt einfach
direkt unseren mixa rein
diese braune stellen habt ist gar nicht
schlimm die kommen einfach mit rein 308
gramm sind perfekt liegt noch in der
toleranz so dann gebe ich hier vanille
dazu und wir können die bananen entweder
zu drücken oder einfach kurz durch mixen
ich mixe jetzt kurz durch ich gebe
einfach noch die eier dazu
dann habe ich schon mal so die flüssige
komponente also kurz pürieren
[Musik]
da nun kommen die zutaten hier ein
ich habe jetzt hier cocos blüten zucker
zum süßen kokos blöden sogar schmeckt
nämlich schon von sich aus total
karamell ich und mal sich ihr könnt
natürlich auch weißen zucker oder
braunen zucker nehmen aber geschmacklich
passt doch schon perfekt dazu schon sehr
lecker dann gebe ich den zucker dazu und
verrührt die zutaten schon mal ein
bisschen cremig
[Musik]
wisst ihr was bevor ich erzählt die
version fertig mache fange ich parallel
schon mal mit der veganen version an
denn da ist sich die eier durch
leinsamen also pro ein könnt ihr 10
gramm leinsamen nehmen also brauche ich
jetzt 20 gramm leinsamen wird die
zerkleinern also schroten mit 70 gramm
wasser denn das muss mal quer
da kann ich mich beides gleicht
gleichzeitig backen und das vielleicht
ganz gut
brauche ich nur einen backofen also noch
vegane version
ich hab's auch ausgewaschen extra damit
dass mich mit ihr in verbindung kommt
das ist nämlich leider auch die bananen
dennoch nicht so ganz reif sind aber ist
okay sie als ich vier stück 300 und da
nehme ich jetzt die leinsamen die werde
ich jetzt gleich hier drin selber
schroten ist auch ganz wichtig denn ihr
braucht diese binde eigenschaft und
diese proteine und das fett aus den
einsamen wie gesagt das wasser dazu
und jetzt kuriere ich so dass es dann
etwa 15 minuten quellen damit die
leinsamen einfach mit dem wasser oder
sich im wasser eben ausbreiten können
okay
[Musik]
mit hits wie gesagt wann der extrakt
noch dazu ist nämlich auch vegan und
dann kann ich die leinsamen erst einmal
quellen lassen und mache mit dem
klassischen bereits ab weiter
also ich hier einfach noch ein paar
minuten verrühren bis sich der zucker
schön auflöst
[Musik]
also beim veganen habe ich wie gesagt
die eier durch leinsamen ausgetauscht
und dann tausche ich noch die butter
einfach durch sonnenblumenöl aus und das
war's im prinzip schon also mehr ist es
gar nicht
jetzt habe ich hier die eier zucker
masse verrührt hier die leinsamen mit
den bananen einfach stehen lassen da
kommt jetzt auch kokos blüten zucker
dazu und jetzt mache ich erst mal ganz
kurz den fertig und dann den ok also das
heißt hier zur flüssigen masse einfach
die trockenen zutaten geben das sind
mehl backpulver und salz und mandeln
ein röhren die butter nämlich auch schon
mit drin
die soll jetzt nicht heiß sondern
einfach nur flüssig sein
da können wir jetzt auch öl nehmen
sofern geschmack ist butter schon immer
ein bisschen besser
so zeigt es fertig ist hier auch die
trockenen zutaten die mandeln und das öl
rein und auch kurz berühren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
42 kasten backformen aus glas die
sprüche jetzt mit back prinz pi ein
das hat auch echt ne schöne menge also
die man einfach mal machen kann wenn man
echt bananen zu viel hat und die etwas
verwerten muss und dann hat man die
einfach schön verpacken so amada vegane
teig dessen bisschen kompakter wenn ihr
euch zu fest das könnte ihnen gerne mit
pflanzen milch einfach auch strecken
[Musik]
das bisschen flüssiger das macht jetzt
aber auch nichts denn da ist ja eine
dran und bin das ganz gut wenn ihr
möchtet nehmt ihr jetzt noch mal eine
banane und schneidet sie längst auf und
legt sie nur obendrauf
dadurch wird das brot oder kuchen so ein
bisschen weniger haltbar also es wird
schneller schlecht aber ich meine mal
hätte sie auch keine fünf tage auf also
so gebacken wäre es dann schon so fünf
sechs tage haltbar
aber ich finde man kuchen ist auch
schnell gegessen von daher kann man auch
schön die bananen noch dazu geben
geschmacklich und optisch richtig cool
und kuchen ist sowieso eher so kompakter
und dafür aber richtig saftig megacool
schnell gemacht tolle bananen
resteverwertung und jetzt kommen sie
direkt im backofen
[Musik]
der banale chor ist fertig und ich habe
ein ganzes meine cousine die schale
hallo ja und schale darf jetzt probieren
der kuchen lässt sich übrigens auch
super einfach aus den formen heraus
selbst einfach raus gestürzt auf so
einem kuchengitter abkühlen lassen
ich glaube leicht warm ist er noch also
einmal standard einmal vegan
ich würde sagen wir probieren einfach
ich bin ich zuerst im mittelteil oder
eher rand stück ein stück her dass man
das probieren so einmal hier
man sieht doch gut aus und so bananen
brot kenne ich von julia sarah sie sagt
nämlich das muss ein bisschen matschig
seinen stimmt sarah sind okay probier
ich komme ja auch schon so schön locker
und trotzdem ist hier das heft ich auch
nicht lecker und ich glaube am nächsten
tag schmeckt noch besser weil er dann so
durchzieht dann sich das aroma zu
entfalten und nicht so süß
echt lecker in der schweiz wegen der
stalker weniger süß mit der ich kann dir
sagen warum hier waren die bananen
reifer und die waren noch nicht so reif
und je reifer umso süßer aber ich finde
es gut weil ich eh nicht so süß mag also
ich finde beide lenker wenn man reife
bananen hat kann man die einfach im
backofen lege für 15 minuten werden die
auch schneller reif habe ich freundlich
und sarah ist es gerne mit erdnussbutter
[Musik]
waren zwar gut aber ich finde wenn man
mal zum beispiel keine eier zu hause hat
oma hat aber voll die reifen bananen und
will die bananen irgendwie verwerten
dann ist das eine coole alternative vor
allem eine coole veganer alternative
ansonsten will ich glaube ich auch er
den machen ja auch super alternative
also mehr sich weiter sehr gut gespielt
und ich glaube wenn man das jemanden
gibt der den man nicht sagt dass das
vega und schmecken auch nicht so
schmeckt schon gut weit ist also das war
s bahnen brote mit erdnussbutter
probiert schlechthin nicht so schreibe
denke daran so und das rezept gibt es in
meiner app 1 der tennis welt app und
natürlich auch auf dem blog auf james
plagt de wir sehen uns wieder haben
nicht nur traums dankeschön das
probieren schon gut
[Musik]